al-shabab started as a resistance
religiously resisting warlords who have
terrorized the Somali people for always
15 years al-shabaab was a small fragment
of that coalition of religious people
who were resisting the waters then if
you'll be invaded Somalia in 2006 after
which at all it's fully up with that my
sense is that the vast majority of the
Somali people knots of mortal Shabaab
there was a 20 and supported them when
they were fighting the occlusions but
that's by a loved one the tragedy of the
case that the government of Somalia and
the international community don't have
the support of the Somali people by and
large because they have not delivered on
the ground in terms of security and all
of those things but al-shabaab is the
least favorite of all the political and
I'm sure if there was a real fair
elections today they may be able to get
2 percent
I survived Abbas majority of the
soldiers are Chancellor's if both the
Somali government Islamic world
international community are really
serious about undermining the al-shabaab
terrorist organization what they do is
put together maybe a couple of hundred
million dollars in one pot and establish
if you like hands for children who come
to those places then get reintegrated as
a skilled people in this country as much
I think that was branched about thousand
to receive very very quickly but nobody
has taken that responsibility seriously
[Music]